[Musique]
bonsoir
alors moi j'aide des jeunes à grandir
dans ce qu'on appelle un fab lab je
pense que certains d'entre vous savent
ce qu'est un fab lab peut-être
quelques-uns ils sont allés mais en fait
qu'est ce que c'est vraiment un fab lab
l'idée du fab lab à l'aîné om haïti à
l'aîné au massachusetts institute of
technology
l'une des universités les plus
prestigieuses du monde neil gershenfeld
a conçu et élaboré un modèle pour ses
cours qui était le bit of atom son idée
c'était qu'est-ce que comment on peut
faire pour programmer la matière comment
avec des machines jeu peut programmer la
matière une des manières les plus simple
de comprendre cette idée c'est de penser
aux imprimantes 3d donc de me dire ok
c'est sympa mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire vraiment concrètement bah en fait
dans un fab lab on peut tout faire
on peut fabriquer des robots peut
fabriquer des drones peut fabriquer des
imprimantes 3d entre autres peut
fabriquer des machines qui fabrique des
machines
en fait on peut faire tout ce qu'on veut
quand on est capable de le faire et en
fait cette idée elle est tellement
extraordinaire qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
milliers de fab lab dans le monde
donc moi personnellement je trouve que
c'est une très bonne idée mais on
pourrait faire mieux je vais m'expliquer
ce qu'on pourrait faire mieux parce
qu'en fait on pourrait dépasser
l'outil de production fab lab on
pourrait penser le fab lab comme un
outil de développement humain nous on en
a fait le pari on a monté deux fab lab
en région parisienne 1 dans 93 et un
dans 95 où on apprend et on aide des
jeunes à grandir
as individus et à apprendre pourquoi
parce que le fab lab contient en
lui-même déjà les germes de plein
d'apprentissage d'apprentissage
par exemple l'apprentissage par
problèmes et peut-être une des choses
les plus intéressantes
pourquoi parce que quand je résout des
problèmes je peux après fabriquer la
solution trouver la solution la faire et
ça c'est extrêmement intéressant pour se
développer
seulement pour pouvoir le faire il faut
aussi développer des compétences trois
compétences sont nécessaires à ça la
première c'est de développer son
attention
la deuxième c'est de développer de la
persévérance et la dernière c'est de
construire de la pensée élaborée sa
pensée en fait ce qui me semble le plus
important là dedans dans ces trois
problème c'est qu'en fait ils peuvent
répondre à une problématique est un
enjeu beaucoup plus grand aujourd'hui on
est tous confrontés à cette
problématique les technologies capture
notre attention
et cette capture d'attention quelque
part détruit un petit peu nos capacités
donc il faut comprendre que sans effort
on ne peut pas apprendre
il n'y a pas de tour de magie même si on
utilise des machines
je vais vous expliquer ce que je fais
avec les jeunes on a fait un atelier par
exemple on devait construire un robot et
voilà je leur ai donné les instructions
pour le faire il avait les modèles 3d
pour le faire donc il suffisait juste de
les imprimer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à le
faire
pourquoi déjà premièrement parce qu'ils
avaient des difficultés pour comprendre
la consigne pas qu'ils comprennent pas
ce qui est écrit simplement parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de méthode et le fab lab peut
aider à ça à force de faire ensuite j'ai
constaté aussi qu'ils avaient des
problématiques de l'ordre de faire
d'assemblées de construire ce robot il
avait des soucis de dextérité on va dire
quelque part une espèce de manque de
lien avec le réel
il faut reconstruire ce lien et le fab
lab peut être cet endroit et pour finir
aussi je leur ai simplement donné les
fichiers 3d à imprimer pour faire le
robot ils pouvaient les modifier il
pouvait faire d'autres choses avec
mais en fait ils ont eu beaucoup de mal
ne serait-ce que deux déjà imprimé ses
pièces tout près fait parce que en fait
utiliser des machines c'est pas
simplement appuyer sur un bouton
en fait c'est aussi déplacé son savoir
faire avec la machine vers la machine
les machines c'est finalement une
extension de nos capacités et il faut
apprendre à les utiliser ensuite
ce que je voudrais dire là dessus c'est
qu' il n'y a pas de bouton magique qui
fera les choses à notre place les
machines c'est pas parce qu'on a pu ratu
qu'elles feront tout à notre place il
faut comprendre que le numérique ne veut
pas nous rendre plus créatifs la
créativité c'est beaucoup plus complexe
par contre le numérique fluidifie nos
apprentissages
ils les simplifier un peu il nous aide à
être un peu plus attentif si on
l'utilisé bien par exemple on a fait un
atelier de design on a design et une
lampe est pareil je suis je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait il y avait plein
de soucis très simple par exemple les
jeunes n'arrivait pas à exprimer à me
dire à partager entre eux qu'est ce
qu'ils voulaient faire vraiment pourquoi
parce qu'ils ne savaient pas dessiner
ils ne savaient pas élaborer un projet
savait pas passer de cette idée à la
réalisation ne serait-ce qu'en 2d ou au
moins être suffisamment capables de le
dire aux autres
donc il faut développer ses capacités il
faut travailler ses capacités le fab lab
peut permettre de les travailler
ensuite j'ai aussi constaté une fois
qu'on avait réussi à résoudre ce
problème qui au final nous a pris quand
même beaucoup de temps et était quand
même un peu inquiétant on a commencé à
faire on va dire les maquettes
donc je leur ai donné de la pâte à
modeler je leur ai donné du carton j'ai
dit allez-y
on va reproduire votre idée maintenant
en vrai en concret avec nos mains parce
que c'est très bien aussi avec les mains
et en fait je me suis rendu compte qu'il
n'arrivait pas à donner forme à la
matière comme ils voulaient n'arrivait
pas à faire apparaître ce qu'il voulait
et il n'arrivait pas à assembler les
cartons les pièces les maquettes comme
il fallait donc finalement je me suis
rendu compte qu'il avait un vrai
problème
il n'arrivait pas à comprendre le réel à
comprendre comment quelque chose tiens
comment une maquette se fait donc en
fait il n'avait pas incorporer ces
contraintes il faut vraiment travailler
sur ça c'est à dire le numérique c'est
pas une opposition
à l'apprentissage il faut d'abord
apprendre pour pouvoir encore continuer
à être plus fort avec le numérique
ensuite pour finir on a numérisé ses
maquettes
une fois qu'on avait enfin réussi à
faire quelque chose de réel de concret
et de physique
on a essayé de les numériser et là je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait ils
n'arrivaient pas à modéliser en 3d il
n'arrivait pas à comprendre ce que
c'était l'espace l'espace dans la
virtualité
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils
n'arrivaient pas à créer de re de lien
entre eux un rond un carré et comment
utiliser ces formes pour pouvoir
développer et faire des choses qui
ressemble à ce qu'ils avaient fait et ça
pareil ça se travaille ça se développe
et cette conscience de l'espace
elle va pas venir par magie la
créativité c'est une compétence c'est
une compétence qui en tant que telle
ce travail se cultive il faut se donner
le temps aussi d'apprendre et se donner
le temps
de développer ses compétences grosso
modo ce qu'on peut se dire de ces
expériences de cet ensemble de choses
que j'ai pu expérimenter avec les jeunes
c'est que le fab lab est un formidable
moyen pour apprendre autrement ils
donnent d'autres manières d'autres
méthodes pour apprendre ce qu'est entre
autres le réel mais aussi les
technologies
il est un peu cet endroit cette passe
entre entre deux espaces il faut il faut
vraiment comprendre que le fab lab est
un espace de socialisation et qui va
permettre à ces jeunes de se développer
au fur à mesure dans leur temporalité
dans leur capabilités comme on dit c'est
à dire dans la capacité qu'ils ont à
acquérir un certain niveau est vraiment
à ce moment-là pouvoir les porter les
aider et à un moment pouvoir les aider à
avoir confiance en eux et donc réussir
le le fab lab
en fait c'est l'outil de demain pour
individuels et jean et il va falloir
qu'on se l'approprient tous voila merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]